how do you like your coffee
dark and soul crushing that was the
number one question on the internet do
you like your coffee to reverberate
deeply through the worst of human nature
is that how you drink your coffee I've
gone through a lot of phases on coffee I
used to in college I would go super deep
into you know grinding fresh beans all
of that kind of stuff water temperature
exactly right and then I hit a phase
where I was just it was the maintenance
dose then I went to like espresso
because I could get a lot more in yeah
and now I go through phases of like
sometimes I like it with a little oat
milk sometimes a little half and half
and sugar if you've gotten soft in your
old age I've gone a little I I have but
hey if I'm doing a SPF interview it's
black that day nothing less yeah it's
black Notions the lights go down what do
you actually do in that in those
situations like uh leading up to a show
do you get hyped up like how do you put
yourself in the right mind space to
explore some of these really difficult
topics
I think a lot of its preparation and
then once it happens it's mostly fueled
by sort of adrenaline I would say
um
I really deeply care about getting to
like the root cause of some of these
issues because I think so often people
in positions of power let off the hook
so I really care about holding their
feet to the fire and it translates into
like
a lot of energy the day of so I never
find myself like funny enough
I usually drink a lot of caffeine
leading up to the interview and then I
try to drink like minimum the day of
because I have so much adrenaline I
don't want to be like hyper stimulated I
have to say of all the recent guests
I've had the energy you you had when you
walked into the door
was pretty interesting people not
excited about here
or something you were very excited um
Like That Just Energy it was terrifying
because I'm terrified of social
interaction anyway uh speaking of
terrifying you chose a good living of
interviewing people for face your fears
my friend